Hãy cho đón sân biển gọi hai y hú trong hai miso, bộ khó học và công nghệ phối hợp tổng công ty biểu định Việt Nam
phát thành buộ têm tích biển gọi và đồng su sư tâm nhìn má phía văn,
là toàn thung nghiệp mai mắn, hai thông và bất phá trong năm mới.
Buộ têm tích biển gọi gồm hai bộ têm và một bước, sau hòa sĩ vĩnh quảng Vinh Thích Tiếc,
thiện hiện thung nghiệp má đảo thành công.
Lấy cảm hứng tử linh bật vự trong văn hoa phương đông, buộ têm được thiện theo phong cách sân dành đường đại
lời bật với hình tưởng vự chiến hồng mau lần đầu sớt hiện trên têm tích Việt Nam.
2 mẫu têm khách hoạc gặp xong mả mạng trong ổn,
biểu chương trời sự hại hoạm, dương, khởi đầu thần lời.
Mẫu bốc lốc mở giống với đàn vự phía nước đại,
nhìn mạnh tinh thần đồng hành và bình biển.
Sau hành cùng bộ têm, đồng su sư tâm nhìn má phía văn mạng hình tưởng vự mặt trời phía mây,
người gắm thung nghiệp vàng giám quan miên, phu hợp lăng qua tạm và bất phẩm su tâm dịt.